[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo antes de la situación de kobe
19 ahora trabajamos desde casa una
colorida campaña impulsada por mujeres a
ghana se ha hecho global en redes
sociales con imágenes en las que se les
ve usando tradicionales vestidos de su
país buscan hacerles saber al mundo que
estas prendas representan la verdadera
cultura de afganistán a diferencia de
los códigos de vestuario impuesto por
los talibanes pero más allá de la ropa
es una forma de alzar su voz por los
derechos que ganaron hace 20 años y que
deben perder bajo el nuevo dominio
talibán empezamos las redes sociales se
han visto inundadas de fotografías de
mujeres afganas que viven en el
extranjero y en las que se les ve usando
coloridos atuendos se trata de una
campaña en línea con la que buscan
hacerle saber al mundo que esa es la
verdadera cultura afgana y no la que han
impuesto los talibanes las usuarias en
internet se mostraron orgullosas de
exhibir los tradicionales vestidos que
se han usado en sus respectivas tribus o
comunidades durante varias generaciones
y que contrasta con la vestimenta oscura
que se ha visto en la capital el país
bajo el nuevo dominio talibán esta
campaña nació como respuesta a lo que
parecía ser mujeres vestidas como nunca
antes se había visto en ese país y que
protestaban en apoyo a los talibanes en
una universidad de kabul en internet se
sugirió que habían sido obligadas a
hacerlo mientras que otros especulaban
que en realidad se trataba de hombres
disfrazados ya que llevaban guantes y
burkas negros en lugar de los clásicos
tonos azules muchas mujeres afganas
alrededor del mundo buscaron la forma de
aclarar que estos atuendos no las
representaban bajar ya la lee una
profesora de historia nacida en ese país
fue la primera en publicar una
fotografía usando su tradicional vestido
de colores y no se imaginó que pudiera
tener este alcance esto dijo a france 24
vi las imágenes en la universidad de
kabul de estas mujeres protalibán usando
algo que nunca he visto en afganistán
que nadie ha visto
todas cubiertas de negro y con guantes
era algo que no es afgano uno no ve esto
ni en las aldeas más conservadoras de
afganistán y mi preocupación era no
quiero que el mundo piense que esta es
la cara de la cultura afgana
siento que las redes sociales e internet
pueden ser una herramienta muy poderosa
para la resistencia cultural
estos vestidos coloridos que viste son
mucho más que una pieza de moda son un
movimiento de resistencia
solo basta hacer una búsqueda en google
imágenes bajo el nombre de ropa afgana
para encontrarse con un sinnúmero de
trajes con variados y coloridos diseños
y ni un solo burka la razón por la cual
este velo islámico- se ha asociado con
la cultura ghana es porque fue
obligatorio durante el primer régimen
talibán entre 1996 y 2001 pero es el
menos común en el mundo musulmán esta
prenda que deja solo una rejilla en la
parte de los ojos suele confundirse con
el niqab que tiene una abertura también
para los ojos o el chador que cubre todo
el cuerpo excepto el rostro
pero ahora usar niqab y otra prenda como
la baya serán requisitos para que las
mujeres puedan asistir a clases
universitarias por eso este movimiento
en línea es también una protesta contra
los nuevos códigos de vestuario exigidos
a las estudiantes alcaraz bajo el
numeral de una touch my clouds que
podría traducirse como no toquen nuestra
ropa rechazaron las nuevas medidas en
las aulas de clase las mujeres además
estarán segregadas de los hombres o al
menos separadas por una cortina solo el
pasado mes de agosto las clases serán
mixtas y nadie estaba obligado a
vestirse de determinada manera así lo
recuerda bajar yalal y quien enseñó en
la universidad estadounidense de
afganistán y allí fundó el primer
programa de estudios de género
y los talibanes están cometiendo
genocidio cultural están atacando
nuestra identidad nuestros paisajes
nuestra historia nuestra herencia
en los últimos 20 años afganistán se
estaba convirtiendo en una sociedad
abierta y tolerante hombres y mujeres
iban a universidades juntos lo que
estamos presenciando es una revocación
de todas esas reformas
es realmente serio y muy alarmante
queremos decir que esta no es afganistán
durante siglos tuvimos gobiernos que
promovieron modernización promovieron
tolerancia y el talibán no es afgano no
representan la cultura plana y no son
aceptados por los actos de
sargent y los talibanes prometieron
respetar los derechos de las mujeres
durante su nuevo dominio pero dijeron
que lo harían dentro de la ley islámica
o 'sharia' una especie de código de
conducta para los musulmanes y al que
los talibanes le han dado una estricta
interpretación desde que tomaron control
del país en 1996 hasta que fueron
derrocados por eeuu en 2001 los derechos
de las mujeres se vieron severamente
restringidos bajo esta ley no podían
estudiar trabajar salir sin un
acompañante masculino de su familia
hablar y reírse en voz alta o dejar ver
su rostro para incumplir estas normas
eran castigadas con azotes o lapidación
es lo que ha generado preocupación en la
comunidad internacional por la forma en
que los insurgentes puedan volver a
aplicar esta ley la importancia sobre
los derechos de las mujeres es la razón
por la cual el movimiento en redes ha
cobrado tanta relevancia en los medios
de comunicación alrededor del mundo el
periódico 'el tiempo' en colombia'
titula mujeres ancianas muestran su ropa
tradicional y desafían a los talibanes
en eeuu el mayor paul se resalta las
mujeres afganas se visten con arco iris
de colores como forma de protesta en
francia el periódico le parisien
registra contra los burkas mujeres
afganas se fotografían con vestimentas
tradicionales
mientras que el portal el confidencial
en españa dice mujeres alternas se
rebelan contra los talibanes en redes
así vestimos nosotros
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra visión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www punto tras 24
puntos
[Música]